we are now hearing from more and more
politicians that they want a $15 minimum
wage wouldn't this cause inflation so
here's what you have to understand about
a question like the $15 minimum wage
every policy that is put in place has
items on both sides of the ledger we've
said wouldn't medicare-for-all kill jobs
yes it would kill some jobs it would
create others it would increase the the
net benefit I believe is very clear for
Medicare for all but it would kill some
jobs and that's another reason not to do
it that's a reason to figure out the way
to do it the right way if you talk about
increasing the minimum wage minimum wage
increases to some degree can accelerate
price inflation the problem is that that
is a talking point being used by the
right to just oppose even common-sense
increases to the minimum wage the
minimum wage has fallen way behind
inflation it has fallen way behind
productivity there is no index that
justifies as low a minimum wage is that
which we have now and the reality is
that labor costs are only part of a
business's total costs so there have
been studies done which suggest if
McDonald's I don't remember the study
exactly but the idea was if McDonald's
goes to a whatever minimum wage 12 $15
whatever that would be a significant
raise for a lot of employees but you
could match that by increasing the cost
of a Big Mac by 10 cents because
averaged into all of that all of that
are fixed costs rent food costs
transportation executive salaries
connectivity and IT systems all of this
different stuff so yes the when you
increase a minimum wage there can be an
inflationary effect but that doesn't
mean we should be scared if you are
increasing the buying power of so many
employees demand side stimulus making
them better able to afford their lives
they have disposable income to go and
spend in their communities which has an
economic multiplier effect the small
inflationary effect on the price of for
example food at McDonald's in order to
give everybody a meaningful raise is a
very valid and Powe
notable trade to be made so when we get
these black and white questions isn't a
$15 minimum wage bad because it'll cause
inflation the question needs to be how
much inflation will it cost and how does
that relate to the overarching cost of
living in these areas and that's where
I've read increasingly very good
economic analyses which say $15 minimum
wage is probably too low in some high
cost of living places but it may be too
high in some other places in low cost of
living parts of the country with a much
lower current minimum wage going to 15
could double the minimum wage that may
be out of line with what the local
economy needs or what the local economic
parameters dictate that's not me being
against the $15 minimum wage in some
places it should be 22 when you look at
cost of living this is me saying that
any one-size-fits-all black-white
thinking about this issue is likely to
be wrong and we have to look at all of
these issues in more detail any policy
has an upside and a downside and
economics the science of economics done
well and economic analyses can tell us
when the benefit outweighs the cost for
the broader betterment of society let me
know what you think we have a great
bonus show for you today don't miss it
become a member at join pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show to get instant access
to today's bonus show